so we have the ability to put video on
it basically any surface right so up in
Novato we did we took an IM Pei building
we wrapped it with video and mapped it
literally down brick for brick so that
the building itself came to life one of
more difficult things to do are things
like Carnegie Hall
so taking 8 video projectors coding
these entire inside of Carnegie Hall
which is you know a very complex 3d
geometric shape and then turning it into
one big video surface
one of the larger projects we've done I
was over at Dubai where they had an
entire village you know 50 villas that
they were launching each one of them we
turned into a projection surface and
synchronized about
so the hardrock project was at one of
our more interesting projects they have
probably the world's largest collection
of rock and roll memorabilia
they came to us and they wanted us to be
able to bring that experience to every
single one of their cafes so what we've
done is we've taken the entire
collection of memorabilia and made it
real-time touch enabled so you can walk
up to a touch screen pick a genre pick a
route pick a band pick whatever you want
search through any of their memorabilia
it'll bring up the items in full
resolution where you can scale in and
you can get inside of like John Lennon's
glasses and see the actual scratches and
the imprint that says you know made in
England
the pool saver we call the cue light we
have a camera tracking application that
looks at the pool balls and in real time
generates procedural video so flames
will be trailing behind the balls or if
they're going really slow ice if they're
coming over a certain area it'll reveal
certain parts of a picture that's
underneath the pool table there's sort
of these dynamic kind of water physics
that we put on it so there's a bunch of
different effects that as you're playing
pool it's just a more entertaining way
to do it so the dome as you see behind
me is that's a 30-foot dome geodesic on
the outside inside of it is a 360-degree
video projector and what that does is it
coats the entire inside of the video so
our software calibrates for that make
sure that it's not over spraying or
under spraying and you know make sure
that if there's buildings inside that
they're appearing straight and what it
does is allow you to kind of step inside
of an environment so an example of
something we've done recently was for
Donald Trump when he was launching his
new hotel and tower in Dubai he couldn't
really fly the 300 executives and VIPs
over to buy so we went over shot
basically 4k hemispherical with the red
camera and brought that footage back and
then when these people in Manhattan came
down they felt like they were in Dubai
so we - on a virtual tour of Dubai
without the plan
we're primarily a marketing company but
the technologies were developing our art
groups malleable into different business
verticals traditionally doctors can look
at flat 2d two-dimensional cat scan PET
scan and whatever kind of data but we're
able to do is take it put it into a 3d
model and using our fire frame engine
put it on to some kind of a touch screen
either multi or single and then allow to
you know either zoom rotate scale and
just get into that model as deeply as
you want it so it's it's providing a
totally different view than doctors
patients radiologists anybody has seen
before if it doesn't exist we'll go out
build it so you know I've got a metal
shop got a wood shop got engineering
facilities you know so if it's a need
that isn't commercially available we'll
fix it
so this is our Visionnaire technology
allows us to draw in the air it's using
an infrared camera to pick up my motions
and then transmitting them back to a
computer where it's processing through a
projector cool part is it appears as if
there's no screen but there's actually a
screen in front of me you just can't see
it it's basically an adaptation of our
framework that is a multi-touch
framework you can see it's actually
tracking my hands scaling and zooming
this is a 23 megapixel image it's also
good for things like this phone to shoot
down some missiles the retail world is
realizing that customers are demanding
new technologies they're used to it you
know even my three-year-old comes up and
starts trying to touch my computer
screen she wants it to do something you
know and as that generation comes up you
need to provide them up an experience
theater in your store in your cafe hotel
restaurant whatever it is cruise ship so
we're working in all those industries to
provide new technologies to endear
entertain inform educate or just you
know generally have fun with in any of
those kind of industries